mmm I like to start really awfully so
that I only get more charming as the
seconds go on in this video that's my
hypothesis but I've never been good at
science hi guys my name is grace Helbig
if you didn't know now you know your
life is different now over the weekend
the Teen Choice Awards happened and on
this channel I like to review red carpet
fashions people showed up to this
televised event wearing things and walk
on a red carpet so it only makes sense
that I as professional analysts review
what they wore I am a professional
analyst I collect part of my income off
of speaking nonsense about clothing on
the internet professional fashion critic
isn't the world we live in completely
senseless let's review the red carpet
fashions from the Teen Choice Awards
what do we have
Lea Michele Lea Michele looks like she's
wearing a variety of curtains it could
also feel like a variety of shower
curtains even me I feel like I'm looking
at a very fashion-forward magic eye it's
all patterns and then as soon as I saw
focus my eyes it's like oh there's Lea
Michele Jessica Alba this looks like a
very high-end Charlie Brown inspired
costumes clothing it's clothing it's not
a costume it's clothing it's clothing
peanuts meets a slightly exploitative
award show all in Maddie Ziegler the
dancer from all the SIA music videos if
you didn't know I'm here to give you
nothing but information Maddie Ziegler
always looks great choice looks her age
she doesn't look like she's trying to be
a sexy sexy teen if there's one thing I
hate more than racism in this world it's
sexy sexy teens but you look super cute
and I like that it looks like you
dropped a hitos on your stomach before
you got to the award show and you just
went with it super cubes Sarah Palin
Sarah Hyland either way Sarah hey
a land ho you're not a ho you look great
you look sophisticated you look like
you're wearing a very expensive drape
and I like it a lot
your dress looks like it's just fighting
so hard to be asymmetrical and it's
doing it and your boobs look symmetrical
ass Wow
uh-oh I gotta look away Gina Rodriguez I
love this outfit so much I want to own
it I want to wear it on Sunday mornings
when it's just me and my dog hanging out
drinking coffee this looks awesome
you look like a little girl just totally
got into her gay dads wardrobe and you
wear it so well Laverne Cox [ __ ] you ah
this is so good this is like Boogie
Nights but like Booga night I don't to
be on an email chain but I want to be on
that belly chain what Shay Mitchell I
want this outfit you look like you stole
a member of the Golden Girls wardrobe
and you just wore them out of it way to
be Arthur
okay by Jason Derulo you look very
stylish you also look like perhaps
you've Shh in your pants and you didn't
have any of the resources to cover it up
but um the apron of a chef that was
nearby you when the pitch cute keke
palmer oh I got two palms and there can
only do one thing after sing stop it how
does your body do that John Stamos ah
just day mostly at my house you look
like you are going to a garden brunch in
the Hamptons
that's exciting you look like an Easter
egg that I want you oh no sorry Stamos
Ian slip Victoria Justice I like this
outfit one because Victoria justice
always looks absolutely beautiful too
because it looks like she caught the
bottom of her dress on something while
she was trying to get out of her house
and
I was like yes I will just tie it in a
bow it's very Project Runway not
completely finished outfit chic and I
like it also is that the eggplant emoji
all over your dress how dare you justice
is served
charlie puth looks like he's having fun
also looks like he's been forever cast
as young zach braff cool Abby Lee Abby
Lee has just fully embraced her role as
retired aunt and I love it this screams
Talbots Cameron Dallas looks like he's
having fun looks like he bought some
patches from Michael's craft store and
made a very fun outfit out of it doesn't
look like he's at any diarrhea recently
in his life so very very fun but I know
there's my review of the red carpet
fashions blue green teal carpet fashions
from the Teen Choice Awards this weekend
let me know who you guys enjoyed seeing
on the carpet and if you enjoyed the
show I haven't watched any of it don't
know a single thing about it probably
miss down a lot of people that I could
have talked about on the carpet and you
probably hate that if you do hate that
subscribe to this youtube channel or if
you don't hate that and you enjoyed any
of this commentary subscribe to this
YouTube channel we're getting really
close the 3 million subscribers that'd
be really fun enjoy your life I don't
know
also I think Jessica Alba might be aging
backwards also maybe just I would died
like years ago and they just keep
sending these wax figures to red carpet
events that take photo says her because
she doesn't age but this is super cute